for now it's about Brady actually
getting himself to the point where he
can be successful where he can be
comfortable where he feels like he can
do the things that he was able to do for
20 years with the New England Patriots
Byron Leftwich the offensive coordinator
of the Tampa Bay Buccaneers who has been
working closely with Tom Brady remember
the incident where Brady accidentally
walked into someone else's house
thinking he was walking back into
leftwich's house back at the time when
there was supposed to be no contact
between coaches and players left which
spoke on the challenges that Brady will
be facing changing teams after 20 years
his left which from yesterday I think
the greatest challenge is this
he's been somewhere for 20 years you
guys know some of you guys may have
worked at the same job for 20 years
you've done something for 20 years in
one spot and there's a change it's
automatically different don't matter if
it's for better or for worse it's just
different and I try to communicate with
him I want him to just talk football I
know you've been saying things a certain
way for so long so when we communicate
we're able to just talk football because
I mean realistically we all kind of run
in the same place is when we called him
how we teach them and how we're trying
to attack them that's different so I
it's not a play that he haven't heard of
it's not a play that he has in rant now
we just got to figure out what he does
well and make sure we run a lot more of
those plays on Sunday than that and he's
right football is football but at the
end of the day you have to get the new
quarterback comfortable with the new
playbook the new coaching staff the new
teammates the new city the new
everything everything changes you're
used to doing things a certain way and
now it's all changing and you have to
get used to that on the fly in an
offseason where you haven't even been in
the facility yet because of the pandemic
now we've talked in the past about how
Brady is taking the lead in working out
with his teammates but Chris what's the
number one challenge we've got some
possibilities here let's start with the
biggest deal of these PlayBook
terminology lack of familiarity with
team
can he do it without Bill Belichick all
of that noise facing the other teams in
the NFC South or something that you have
explained in the past the the swamp but
dynamic in which widget which is the
biggest thing that he's going to have to
deal with from an adjustment standpoint
well as much as I'd like to sit here and
have fun with the swamp but part of it
he'll adjust to that and you know as
we've seen he's already got some tricks
to do lesser than the sweat that's
coming out of the center's you know
crack there anyways when you're taking a
snap but regardless I think the big
thing is to me Mike
is the language of the offense the
terminology the playbook you kind of
heard Byron Leftwich just discuss that a
little bit how he's trying to talk
football Brady's been talking one way
for 20 years right you know to to use it
for lack of a better way to kind of put
this out there yeah he's been speaking
English for 20 years now he's going
somewhere else where you know the
dialects a little different he's
speaking Spanish he's gotta kind of
learn it on the fly here and yes he's
not gonna necessarily to be in the
building every day you know talking it
with other players on a daily consistent
basis so that will be the big thing just
flipping things around in his brain to
go oh wait
okay this formation meant this in New
England and now we call it this in Tampa
Bay so between that mic and then I think
there's even more to this then I think
the next phase of it is the B what do I
want to say here I had this written down
but the merging of the two offenses I
think is the next thing because I don't
think Tom Brady can just run Bruce
Arians drop-back stand in there and get
crushed offense and I also don't think
you'd be benefitting from Tom Brady and
all that he can bring to the table if
you made him do that all the time
so I would expect Bruce Arians and Byron
Leftwich to go hey showing all those Wes
Welker Julian Edelman plays you ran over
the years and I think it's gonna be
about finding that that merge point to
where it works and I think if they can
find the right formula there Mike I
think it helps Bruce Arians offense I
think it helps Tom Brady and it could be
a merit you know a match made in heaven
there where it could be the perfect
type of offense that has a little bit of
everything sorry for the long answer
there that's fine on the surface it
would be easier to assimilate Brady into
the way the Buccaneers already do things
but it's smarter to have that mutual
assimilation where Brady is learning the
new coaching staff the new teammates the
new playbook the new terminology but at
the same time the team is moving toward
him that's why they wanted him they want
Brady they want what he does well so
they have to adjust their approach to
mesh with what he does well there's a
middle point there even though it
spreads that burden onto a lot more
people it's a lot easier to just say hey
we got a new quarterback he's gonna
learn our offense everybody else keep
doing what you've been doing no big deal
and off we go no we want all the other
players to shift toward Brady because
they know the end result is going to be
the team is better and that's what makes
it harder in a pandemic to get everybody
where they need to be because it's not
just Brady becomes a Buccaneer it's the
Buccaneers also become basically
Patriots yeah very real and I think that
was a great way to explain it Mike yeah
guys like Chris Godwin Mike Evans
they're gonna they're gonna have new
plays and things in the offense and
especially I think Chris Godwin who
plays that slot position and as it is
obviously one of the best slot receivers
in football he is going to I think have
a new group of plays that he's never
really run or gonna have an
understanding for it that's what it does
think about that pandemic and no OTAs
you know a lot of those plays too and
what Brady Britt made pretty so magical
over the years is Welker and Edelman
such smart guys almost like an extension
of the quarterback to themselves to
where they could always read the
coverage in the middle of the field and
a lot of these times but these routes
are called for people out there who are
wandering jerk routes because you try to
make a guy in the middle of the field
look like a jerk because the receiver
will have the option to go basically for
different directions you have option
routes which is like a similar thing but
you can only go three different ways and
I think those are the big things you're
gonna see in this offense I think it
would only be smart for Tampa Bay I
think it's good for Tom Brady of course
but I think it's best for that team in
that offense to kind of merge that
together and I think it'll only make
Brady better and it's gonna make the
meat-and-potatoes big Bruce Arians down
the field passing plays better to Mike
cuz it's gonna give another element of
the offense that teams are gonna worry
about now you're not worried about Bruce
Arians going deep deep deep deep all the
sudden you're going man Godwin's killing
us over the middle or underneath
underneath underneath and then all of a
sudden zoom a laser go buys they're
headed with spike Evans down the field
for a 40 yard gain and I think that's a
pretty good combination even though in
so many ways Tom Brady looks like he was
carved out of a rock and he's a robot
and he's timeless and ageless and he's
so different than the rest of us mere
humans and some level he is human I
suspect do you think he's nervous at all
what do you think he's feeling about
this transition that he's going through
after 20 years of being in the same
place doing the same thing with the same
coaches and not the same players
obviously because they change but
everything's the same for him all the
time now everything's different do you
think there's gonna be anxiety that that
will maybe even manifest itself in Tom
Brady I mean anxiety may be a
nervousness of the unknown a little bit
and probably the fact that he still
hasn't met the majority the coaches in
the organization and I'm sure there's
still a ton of players he hasn't been
around so kind of wondering well what's
it gonna be like what's the schedule
maybe that but I mean nervous nervous
Mike like this is one of the more
conditioned nervous systems I think in
America you know when you're talking
about a guy who's 9 Super Bowls and it
seems like in every one of them he had
the ball on the last Drive of the game
to go win it and it never seems like he
was nervous for 3 seconds in his life
and any football game I've ever seen I
just think he's one built for this type
of stuff and to you know because of all
the big moments and everything like that
I would think he's almost numb
the nerves of once he gets on the field
and starts playing and throwing and
doing things like that that would be my
tape you know I can't speak to it I
don't know what it's like to be in a guy
like Tom Brady shoes they don't too many
people on earth that can really you know
know what that feels like but I would
think yeah it's just the other stuff
that's maybe nervous it's not the
football stuff I think they'll handle
that fine and you said he hasn't met a
lot of the coaches when you look at the
entire Buccaneers coaching staff I was
just skimming through there there's
gonna be multiple members of the
coaching staff we were younger than Tom
Brady including Byron Leftwich who
entered the AFL 3 years at me Tom Brady
was drafted 2003 one of the first-round
picks that year rattle him off the
first-round picks were were you know do
you know Carson Palmer
Byron Leftwich Kyle Boller and not
christened some still pissed off about
it Mike yeah baby that's why I mentioned
it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports